Ergonomically designed to fit within the palm of your hand,...
...Fold's compact outer display is the first...
...to enable truly one-handed, on-the-go responses.
Fold's app continuity seamlessly configures your favorite apps...
...while the software optimization with Google...
...allows you, for the first time on mobile, to watch a video on Youtube,...
...text your friend about it and book your stay, all at the same time.
When it comes to capturing your own content,...
...Fold's prograde, six-camera system makes every angle epic,...
...from everyday spontaneous moments to the triple rear system,...
...to capturing unsurpassed 123 degrees ultrawide shots.
Available as both a 4G and 5G model,...
...its unparalleled, high-speed performance comes from not one...
...but two batteries, which combine to form a single revolutionary energy cell,...
...giving you the power to share power on even on the go.